c'est à vous je vous rappelle pas le
visage a les cheveux surtout pas trop ce
que la peau vous donne une indication
absolument pas
[Musique]
ravissante
et les magnifiques n'était pas elle
croit qu'on va passer la seconde revient
si l'on peut voir le déçu à la bonne
hauteur mais il faut bien vérifier quand
même chose
attention troisième candidate
vous êtes juste devant est juste à la
bonne hauteur justement il va falloir
prendre une décision amène maintenant tu
peux plus vous laisser le choix de tel
c'était lui qui sûr on garde
je crains que ce soit perdu qu'est ce
qui vous a trompé c'est peut-être
l'ambiance
[Musique]